Hello, my name is Zisl Slepovitch
and I'm a musician-in-residence at Yale
University's Fortunoff Video Archive
for Holocaust Testimonies.
This video series is
designed as a companion
to our album, Where Is Our Homeland,
which is the first volume in the Archive's
ongoing effort to present songs
and poems performed by survivors in
testimonies given to the Fortunoff Archive
over the last 40 years.
You can learn more about the project on the
Archives website, songsfromtestimonies.org.
Where Is Our Homeland?
Songs from Testimonies Volume One was
recorded in 2019 by
the Zisl Slepovitch Ensemble featuring
renowned singer Sasha Lurje,
Craig Judelman on the violin, Joshua
Camp on the accordion,
keyboards and guitar,
Dmitry Ishenko on the bass, and myself
on woodwinds.
The songs in this
collection differ vastly in
terms of style, social and historical
background, language, and many other
aspects, but collectively they
create a multidimensional picture of
Jewish life before and during World War II.
This song that we're going to talk about
and listen to today
was the song of
the Płaszów inmates.
It was sung, or
rather recited as a poem
by Ruth C.,
a native of Kraków, Poland,
where she was born in 1920.
During the Holocaus, Ruth
survived several labor camps
and concentration camps
in both her native country and in
Germany.
The inmates wrote
this poem. They were quietly passing
it on to
each other as a means of hope
for survival, as a hope
to escape from
the deadly cemetery gate
as the song goes.
I can tell you the whole song in Polish
Every morning at five,
The trumpet wakes us up.
With its familiar call
To the Appelplatz.
We stand straight in rows,
Looking into the distance,
Looking to escape
This cemetery gate.
Dark night hovers over the roofs,
The city is sound asleep.
Only we — just one more step,
And the heart will die in pain.
Something like this,
but perhaps the last stanza
isn't completely correct,
but this is the song.
Every morning at five,
The trumpet wakes us up.
With its familiar call
To the Appelplatz.
We stand straight in rows,
Looking into the distance,
Looking to escape
This cemetery gate.
Dark night hovers over the roofs,
The city is sound asleep.
Only we — just one more step,
And the heart will die in pain.
The lyrics of this hymn were led by a
survivor of the Płaszów concentration
camp named Ruth Cohen,
who believes it was written by one of her
fellow inmates.
It speaks to the terrible feeling that
prisoners felt at roll call,
appelplatz, every morning at 5:00 a.m.
in the camp, when the prisoners lined
up and felt as if they are one step
away from death.
The notorious camp
commander, Amon Göth,
who was portrayed by the actor Ralph Finnes
in the film Schindler's
List, would sometimes
randomly shoot the prisoners at a whim
during his roll calls.
Płaszów represented more than the deaths
of individuals.
Płaszów represented the death of the Kraków
Jewish community.
So by thinking about the Kraków Jewish
community before the Holocaust, we
can better appreciate the immensity of the
loss.
Kraków had been a major religious center.
Throughout the early modern period, it was
home to several leading rabbinical figures
such as Rabbi Moses Isserles,
Mordechai Jaffe, Joel Sirkes.
The visitor to Kraków today can still
see the Old Synagogue's
testament to its former glory, the
Old Jewish Cemetery.
But by the interwar period, Kraków Jewry
had become much more diverse.
Kraków was home to theaters, cabarets,
literary cafes.
The great folk songwriter Mordechai
Gebirtig, who lived in Kraków,
wrote the song Es brent,
Our Town Is Burning,
a defiant song calling on
Jews to rise up and defend
themselves during the pogroms in the late
1930s.
Kraków is also home to many Hasidic Jews,
followers of the great Bobover Rebbe
and the Belzer Rebbe.
And it was home to a teacher seminary
to train teachers for Orthodox
and Hasidic girls and women.
Kraków was also a major Zionist center,
and this was the affiliation of Ruth Cohen
and her family.
The great rabbi, Ozjasz Thon,
preached in the temple synagogue
and was a fervent Zionist.
The Sejm, or parliament deputy,
Apolinary Hartglas, was also
a Zionist and lived in Kraków.
In the wake of World War I,
during the pogroms that occurred in Kraków,
the Zionists were absolutely crucial to the
formation of Jewish self-defense
units.
And after this, they formed a
major newspaper, Nowy Dziennik,
which had a circulation of around fifteen
thousand.
Zionists held about half the seats
and the Kehila or the Jewish communal
self-government.
The other half was held
by Hasidic and assimilationists Jews.
There was also a very popular Zionist youth
group named Akiba, which would
perform a major role in
self-defense during the Holocaust.
Ruth Cohen describes
her upbringing in Kraków
as occurring between two worlds,
one Polish, one Hebrew.
Ruth attended the Zionist
gymnasium where they would learn,
study in Polish half the day and
in Hebrew the other half of the day.
She thought of herself as really
a Zionist, but her family
did not have any thoughts of immigrating
to Palestine.
They tried to escape
when the war broke out,
but it was just too late.
First, they lived in the Kraków ghetto
and then on March 13th,
they were deported,
along with most of Kraków
Jews to the Płaszów concentration camp.
By this time, there were about twenty
thousand Jews were prisoners there.
And the camp was run by the notorious Amon
Göth, the sadistic SS Kommandant
Oskar Schindler's
enamel factory was located
adjacent to the camp.
Göth and the other guards shot thousands
of Jews and deported thousands
more to their deaths in Auschwitz.
According to Ruth, everyone was afraid
all the time, but especially
terrified at 5:00 a.m.
in the morning, when they would line up
for roll call, Appelplatz.
The song, the Hymn of Płaszów ,
reads as follows: Every morning at 5:00,
the trumpet wakes up with its familiar call
to the Appelplatz.
We stand in straight rows.
If a hand were to signal in the distance,
we would all escape as soon as possible
from the cemetery gate.
Dark night hovers over the roofs, the city
is sound asleep, only we just one
more step, and the heart will
die in pain.
It's especially poignant
to compare this song
to the pre-war song by Gebirtig,
Es brent, Our Town is Burning,
which urged the Jews to rise
up against their persecutors and
fight.
And certainly during the Holocaust,
members of youth group Akiba
did just that.
However, a more
representative feeling is probably captured
in this song, a feeling of despair,
a feeling of terror, a longing
for escape that rarely occurred.